Obviously is quite a problem
how do you make D2O, because normally
the deuterium in the water is diluted by
a factor of seven thousand. Which for
chemist is really pretty dilute.
The best way of making D2O is by a process
called electrolysis when you pass a
current through the water to make
hydrogen. The process was first carried
out on the large scale in Norway just
before the second world war.
In Norway which is a very mountainous country they
have a lot of cheap electricity from
hydropower.
Rivers going over waterfalls. So they
have electricity and it makes economic
sense to generate hydrogen to make ...
for making ammonia and fertilizers by
electrolyzing water. And if you
electrolyze water you find that the H2O
react a little bit faster than the D2O.
So if you go on electrolyzing more and
more of water and keeping what's left
and then doing several stages of
electrolysis you can gradually
concentrate more and more of the D2O
To eventually it's nearly pure. This process was
carried out in a fairly remote power
station in central Norway. In a region called Telemark. Now, one of the main uses of
D2O in the early stages of nuclear
science was for making nuclear reactors.
Nuclear piles, and during the Second
World War the British and the Americans
were terrified that Germany who occupied
Norway in ... that time might get
hold of the D2O and start nuclear
research. And in one of the best raids of
the whole Second World War six
Norwegians
attacked the power station, destroyed the
heavy-water apparatus and retreated.
And the reason it was so successful is that
nobody was injured and nobody was killed.
So they got into the place blew it up
and escaped without anybody being
injured and in fact the German General
that investigated thought it was one of
them as magnificent military feats
he'd ever seen. There's another story
that before the Germans invaded Norway,
that the supply of heavy water - two cans - a few gallons, was smuggled out to the UK.
And it was so valuable it is said that
it was put under King George VI bed
overnight so it should be safe before it
was then transported to America.
Is that true?
Well this is the the legend and the
story is that when it was flown to
America in an unheated plane
the water froze, so when the people took
it off
it sounded as if the cans were empty and
they got really worried but then it
warmed up and melted.
D2O has a number of applications but
it's real use is in a technique called
nuclear magnetic resonance.
We have shown it on our video about tea,
how you can use it to analyze molecules.
And nuclear magnetic resonance is very
sensitive to hydrogen atoms.
So if you want to study some sort of molecules
dissolved in water
if you use ordinary water, the hydrogen
atoms in the water have such a strong
signal, that you can't study the
dissolved molecules at all.
So instead you use D2O which do not
respond to the same frequencies as the
hydrogen and so you get a nice spectrum.
[Brady] I think people watching will have two
questions.
What does heavy water tastes like? And
what will happen to me if I think it?
Well, I've never tasted D2O.
I suspect that it will taste really
quite similar to H2O. Though it's
difficult to predict because sometimes
things taste quite different, but water
doesn't really taste anyway,
you usually tastes what's dissolved in
the water salts or whatever.
There is a strong body of opinion that D2O is
quite poisonous and the reason why it's
poisonous is because in your body you
have all sorts of molecules that have
hydrogen bonded particularly to oxygen. And these bonds break as part of the
various chemical processes in your body.
Deuterium oxygen bonds are slightly
stronger than hydrogen oxygen bonds and
therefore if you start changing your
body for the the chemicals in your body
from hydrogen to deuterium these bonds
will break more slowly. And so various
processes in your body are likely to
slow right down.
If they slow down they may completely
stop.
Well I was always told that you could
kill someone by making a cup of tea
with D2O.
Because what it does
is there a difference between the way
that hydrogen reacts and deuterium reacts
in the body so it can replace hydrogen
in the body and obviously its everywhere
it's in the water and it's in all the enzymes
that are in your body.
But I have since read that
apparently you need to replace about fifty
percent of the water in your body. For
actually kill you with D2O, which is
kind of impractical.
So ... would be murderers don't try that one, it will not work.
There is a rumor which I never been able to verify that the Argonne lab in the United States just outside
Chicago at one time had deuterated a
dog, which had been brought up and fed on D2O.
But I think this is probably just a
urban myth, and it never happened.
There's also a suggestion that if you
dilute your whiskey with D2O rather
than H2O, that you might not get so dizzy
when you drink too much.
But you might be dead so it's not
something that one should try and anyway
it's far too expensive.